know you today too
[Music]
Genius I'm
tired of hearing it, I'm going to come up with another word
[Music]
Bash version Let's talk a little bit What is
this? Don't come
in without permission
[Music]
If you're interested, I can't help but tell you something special.
This is the process of
manufacturing condensed magic weapons. The
main ingredient is mithril, which has a high rate of absorbing magical power, and several other
magical raw materials are mixed together.
By continuing to compress it, they create a super bomb that stores hundreds of times the original amount of magical power.
With this, I
will reign as the greatest Four Heavenly Kings of all time,
but Mithril wasn't really needed.It's not a
problem.I'm delivering at four times the pace.It looks like the
site is going to be tough.That's why it's okay.That mine
is Dariel's.  You'll want to bully people for no reason in a
place where their accomplishments remain.
[Music] That's the
thing. The
Mithril Mine has been taken away. It's
already occupied by humans.
[Music]
The situation is even more serious.
Is there anyone else you want to complain to? Who
is that person who has an opinion about me? I'll
kick you out of the demon lord.
It's the demon lord.
[Music]